pranger
vous connaissez jean philippe marthély
dans cette dynamique
[Musique]
mais surtout réputé pour provoquer des
réactions de ce genre
[Musique]
sa vie d'artiste ses 40 ans de carrière
chanteur au sein de plusieurs gros
pipeau c'est son surnom
il est réputé pour être bien entouré
avant chaque prestation
je vais mieux voir un pipeau pipeau avec
l'ambiance à ce conflit pour faire
l'ambiance lambert faire le plus beau
tous les outils sont donc réunies pour
permettre à notre chanteur de réussir sa
soirée dans la joie la joie l'amour
voilà c'est avec ça que je fonctionne
moi l'amour l'amour l'amour l'amour bien
d'autrui
c'est formidable après ces énergies reçu
c'est le moment de s'isoler 15 minutes
avant de monter sur scène autre artiste
a besoin de se recentrer
nous ne le dérange non plus ses
partenaires de scène non plus il révise
donc leur répertoire et partitions pour
s'imprégner un petit peu du numéro 3
même si on connaît déjà le manchot pour
s'imprégner un petit peu de ce
combattant du temps leur mais à bien ça
aide à se mettre déjà dans l'ambiance
c'est au tour du groupe de passer la
scène leur appartient désormais on va
faire le maximum à 100 cela premièrement
les parties pour le carnaval
[Musique]
marie moussa abou sarie l ambiance
toujours avec jean-philippe j'évoquais
leurs habitations
[Musique]
un super public comme comme je m'y
attendais sont venus vous savez je
venais beaux jours et puis tu peux et
caprices sans allumer
[Musique]
connor tous les jours gras ce sera comme
ça avec la borne à pied pourquoi tous
ont droit sera dit fabrice aux animaux
le chat
ça va